before the pandemic hit euphoria's
second season was way darker it's far
from a happy show but during filming
many scenes were changed to better
accommodate the actors and the needs of
the series we're diving into just how
much changed along the way to bringing
euphoria to our screens
number one this girl has not had it easy
ruse had a rough go facing trial after
trial and at the end of the second
season she was initially meant to
continue to spiral to the lowest of lows
but lucky for everyone sam levinson and
zendaya decided to give roo a shot
working their way through the series it
became evident that there needed to be
something to hope for and if anyone
deserves a break it's rude the
character's journey in the second season
still goes to very dark places that
they'd plan to explore but instead of a
total catastrophe rue gets by with a few
scars and thank goodness because we are
not ready to see her story end anytime
soon number two less drama can't always
count on it in euphoria let's throw back
to nate and maddie's messed up russian
roulette scene the intense interaction
was a tough one to watch and especially
for the actors to film and they almost
got out of doing it completely none of
this drama would have ensued had they
gone with the original storyline maddie
anonymously delivering the explicit disc
to jewels in this far less dramatic
scenario we would have seen something
very special that even alexa demi was
looking forward to there was a part of
me that really wanted to see that happen
i think the way it goes down keeps the
story going and it's drama that's for
sure
number three everything was left on the
floor in this one believe it or not this
scene didn't start out so brutal when
the actors first dove into it it was a
pretty lackluster argument devoid of a
fiery passion we know these two are
capable of sidney sweeney wasn't shy to
speak up about it we were like there's
so much more here that we could do
that's pent up let's build it they
didn't have to ask levinson twice as
soon as sweeney suggested they go bigger
levinson churned out five pages worth of
dialogue and lordy and sweeney gave it
their all
number four anyone wonder where cat's
been the audiences miss her but rumors
from behind the scenes seem to have some
answers as to why barbie was hardly in
the second season according to crew
members barbie and levinson weren't
getting along so well because she didn't
agree with the direction levinson was
planning for cat mainly a storyline
about cat having an eating disorder it
was a no-go for the actress although
barbie has been vague about what the
deal is with her character in the second
season cat's journey this season is a
little more internal and a little
mysterious to the audience she loses her
marbles a bit just like everyone else in
the season the theme is everyone's gone
a little crazy barbie did walk off set a
couple times and with that kind of
tension between herself and the director
came a lot less screen time for cat
number five it bothered the actors as
much as it bothered us martha kelly was
actually in tears reading the scene
between her and roo at her house while
she was on the run laurie seems to be
taking decent care of rue drawing for a
bath and getting her some morphine but
in the original script kelly was meant
to fully undress zendaya before getting
her into the tub and
well let's just say this scene was
leaning towards major creepy vibes so
intense that kelly didn't even feel
comfortable filming it the actress
didn't request for anything to be
changed but she did talk to levinson
about her discomfort in the end the
director changed it leaving the camera
more out of focus than initially planned
for the scene and pulling back on those
creepy vibes
number six on the very first day maddie
and samantha's oddly sensual moment when
maddie unzips samantha's dress
originally saw minka kelly's dress
dropped to the floor leaving her totally
exposed kelly wasn't totally feeling it
not understanding why it was necessary
since she didn't even know very much
about her character or what her
storyline was going to be at that point
the actor was ready to work but she told
levinson she'd be filming with her dress
staying on the whole time and the
euphoria creator didn't put up a fight
about it
number seven this might be one of the
best couples on euphoria we actually
have mod apatow to thank for the sexy
romance i love angus i hope he loves me
back chatting on the phone with levinson
for hours led to the two realizing just
how great a match lexi and fez would be
angus and i in real life have a funny
friendship it all just happened it all
felt right as soon as we started talking
about it it feels right to us too
number eight how much more exactly we
see cassie very exposed throughout the
series even when she's wearing clothing
like the legendary pink bathing suit
shockingly this was a lot less than
originally planned multiple scenes were
written to have sydney sweeney topless
but the actress didn't always feel it
was necessary to the story levinson's
response okay we don't need it and for
sweeney that worked she never felt like
sam has pushed me or was trying to get a
nude scene into an hbo show when i
didn't want to do it he didn't make me
number nine every script is a new
adventure nate is unpredictable on
euphoria and it turns out his plot
points are a bit unpredictable for jacob
allordy too the actor has a basic idea
of what's to come for his character
while filming but more and more he found
himself in scenes that were created
spontaneously leaving the actor no
choice but to go with the flow no matter
where the euphoria train took him the
actor got to a point where he just had
to embrace whatever intense content came
his way and react to it all in real time
as it happened
number 10 it's hard to tiptoe around
just how intense the show can be chloe
cherry was used to being pretty exposed
on camera but she wasn't expecting to be
totally naked filming her very first
scene for euphoria the actress didn't
say much about it but her scene partner
wasn't a fan thinking it would be
excessive especially considering the
fact that the two actors had literally
just met levinson was on board to get
cherry fully clothed and they went on
filming the actress was still covered in
fake blood but having clothing on was a
bit of a lighter way to go
number eleven tense conversation
emotional realizations these two had it
all but off the bat of filming their
special episode they were kind of let
off the hook levinson had to do
something i remember he added the very
last bit of the scene where she says i
don't want to be here anymore he added
that late we got those pages maybe two
days before we were going to shoot it
coleman domingo embraced the changes
that came his way even with quick
turnaround times for learning the
scripts luckily it's not hard to
memorize because everything has an
action and they help build on the other
thought and so i find that you can
manage his scripts if you're just honest
and you go on the ride and what a ride
it is
number 12 he did kind of have it coming
nate doesn't have an easy go in the show
but he is in the show a lot which is
very different from the original plan
his story was meant to start and end in
the pilot the script initially saw
nate's body being found in a cornfield
after roo took him out yeah we're in
shock too euphoria really is tough on
its characters
number 13 he almost saw the end too soon
the actor suspected fesco wasn't going
to be around much anyway but he didn't
make too many assumptions when he first
began then once the pilot was being shot
jacob allordy mentioned what was in
store for fesco and it wasn't pretty the
character was meant to be a goner in the
first season but after the team
witnessed just how magnetic the actor
was on screen they knew they'd better
keep him on the show cloud was pretty
gracious about the whole thing anyway i
don't know how i was going out but
hopefully i would have gone out like a g
we have no doubts he would've
number 14 we thought there was a lot to
begin with anyone remember the explicit
locker room scene in the first season we
saw a whole lot more private parts than
we'd anticipated but in fact what we saw
was the toned down version the homage to
a similar scene in the movie carrie
originally had over 100 appearing but it
was a no-go from hbo
number 15 we could have seen rue from
the very beginning off the top of the
first season of euphoria we get an image
of a baby in utero cute but the original
scene was a full-on berth with the
camera zooming right into leslie's legs
as she was having room hbo felt it was
too intense even for them and for
levinson this particular sequence wasn't
really worth fighting for just how
intense can euforia get it feels like
the options are endless and with such a
versatile cast and crew we get raw
emotional and pretty special moments
even if they are pretty dark
which scene would you like to see done
differently
[Music]